it's the busiest time but it's the most
exciting time but you know it's it's
when this city comes to live hey guys
I'm right here at the Ritz Carlton
Toronto and the party definitely got
started last night now this is the sixth
year that the hotel is but involved in
the festival so they served up a six
hundred dollar cocktail now afterwards
everybody headed over to the world
premiere of the Magnificent Seven let me
tell you something this cast is nothing
short of magnificent I got to sit down
with the whole gang earlier today
I'm sweating things were a little steamy
on the red carpet for this western
reboot and we're not just talking about
heat check out Chris Pratt's bedroom
confessions I got my whole wardrobe I
always for the old lady she likes it
that is not all Cameron got out of Chris
you seeing Oh Shenandoah got you the
park is there like truth to that
yeah sort of can you give us a little
taste just to bump it out for us did you
go to the gym this morning Gary good man
we just has that thing that you know
chicks love him and he's alright with
the guys so denzel's impressed with
Chris's four-year-old son Jack not so
much I said hey Jack hey Jack you don't
see me dressed up as a cowboy I said
yeah it says right there any luck huh
Toronto's film festival is one of the
largest in the world we'll see Leo Reese
and Mathew here this weekend but last
night it was brie Larson's night she
owned the red carpet at the premiere of
her new movie free fire you basically
broke her a gun deal gone wrong in real
life how was your negotiating skills
I've been pretty good I'm not afraid to
ask for what I want we can't
the cameras just getting warmed up wait
till Monday he's going to have more huge
stars from Toronto